[موسيقى]
لسه بلديه يدفعه والاغلب الدول العربيه
اللي عن تحقيق علاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
فلسطين هو الاحتلال المستمر المناطق
الفلسطينيه
ومنعها وحق المصير الفلسطينيين هذه
التي
رفضها الجامعه الدول العربيه تحت قياده
الملك عبد الله راح الملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولا تزال هذه سياسه الجامعه
العربيه على رقمنا بعض الدول مثل الاماره
العربيه المتحده والمغرب والبحرين تنعت عن
هذه السياسه واما فيما يخص كم يكفي
فالحكومه الاسرائيليه تقيم بشكل كبير
تحسين العلاقات مع تلك الدول التي ذكرتها
انفا ولكن كل الاسرائيليين يرغبون بعلاقات
كامله مع كل دول المنطقه وبهذا الخصوص
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي بلا شك
الجائزه الاكبر بالنسبه لهم ورئيس الوزراء
نتانياه لو كانت له امنيه واحده
حتى امنيه زملائه ان تكون هناك علاقات دون
ماسيه كامله مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
داخل الولايات المتحده نعم وكما ذكرتي
فان السياسه المعلنه
للادارات الامريكيه
المتتاليه كانت لدعم فكره تحقيق الاستقرار
بين الفلسطيني والاسرائيليين ولكن
الولايات المتحده لما تستخدم اي سلطه لها
على اسرائيل ولا حتى الفلسطينيين ولكن
بشكل خاص على اسرائيل
الدعم الاقتصادي والدبلوماسي المستمر
اعتقد بان الوضع الحالي
اظهر وظهر مؤخرا عندما
حتى رئيس بايدن حكومه نتنهاء على عدم
الاستمرار بخططها لي يتجاوز
مساء الخاصه بالقضائي في فلسطين وتسببت
بالكثير من الجدل واستجابه لاحد وزراء
الاسرائيليين قال لا تهتم بشؤون اهتم
بشؤونك الخاصه
فالاداره الحاليه تريد ان
التحدث الشجاعه الداخليه اللي تواجه
اسرائيل بعضها هذه الحقائق
[موسيقى]